yeah hello welcome to this video
different kind of setup here because I'm
on chest tempo calm doing chest tactics
yeah I've not done this kind of video
for a while but I will return to that
and I'm doing it now on chest tempo when
I did some of those tactics videos um a
couple of months ago early this year I
think were the last ones that was on
chest c'mon that tactics trainer but
back then people already said okay why
don't you use chest tempo because it's
better yeah it is somewhat better
tactics trainer and I use chest comm at
the time because they yeah they proposed
me to do it and for a little
compensation it's not a bad tactics
trainer really know they can use it you
can use it fine but now that I don't
have any contractual obligations to
chest calm I'm doing a chest tempo
because this is where I always did it
when I can miss it more time on on
tactics training for myself so this is
the first position here we're doing it
without any time time involved yeah
they're they have standard tactics where
you can take as much time as you want
and they have blitz tactics where the
time spent counts towards the result I'm
doing the standard because I want to
want to be able to to talk about the
positions and not being and so much of a
rush think it it makes some sense and
that in that context so I'm going to do
a couple of positions I don't show how
many because they are typically rather
difficult I mean you get positions that
are that hit your rating and my rating
here is not super high but it's been a
while since I'd been only a but my
experience is that it is pretty it's
pretty tough
so um that's the first position and
blacks move here was Queen takes f6 and
now we need to find the best move for
white yeah first of all what is going on
in this place
like just has captured what did he
capture by the way captured a night
uh-huh
so okay the first thing that is quite
obvious is said white can yeah can can
take that can take that Queen but if you
take the Queen on f6 the problem is
probably going to be some stalemate
issue like Queen f6 it's them it's lucky
getting a stalemate going mmm yeah
here's a queen takes f6 I don't think I
don't think I can put it on the board
right that would be cheating yeah okay
Queen f6 there's some a couple of checks
that black can play but he has rook H to
check which is very forcing Luke H to
check King takes H to rook G - checking
takes G - and it's stalemate and the
King cannot move and the Jeep on also
cannot move so rou gauge to check King
h2 and root G to check King can go back
to h1 and then you go King loop g1 check
and however y takes it's a draw so Queen
takes f6 is drawn can white do better
than that
this is to be checked the thing is that
the only thing really that black has is
those stalemate ideas he doesn't have a
perpetual check you can check on h3 g3
but you cannot check on f3 necessarily
if I take so I wonder if I can play rook
h7 check King takes age 7 and then Queen
f6 this would make sure that there's no
stalemate the queen is covering h4 okay
that's not relevant but it covers the FR
so rook h3 check kim ji-won rook g3
check King f1 and then look at future
can be taken I think that's the solution
Queen takes f6 it's no good because of
the stalemate so I'm giving that check
yeah I'm right up to here and here
Queen f6 has to be done so that was a
correct solution
not too difficult I learned a couple of
points there
yeah I'm gaining lots of points for a
problem because I was soem inactive for
a long time I actually see that user to
one something to 195 plus 40 yeah you
don't gain that much usually to 195 it's
not brilliant in standard on chess
temple but it's quite okay when I was
doing this regularly I was about 2300
which is pretty okay so let's see let's
go for the next problem
mmm the the screen SAP I'm not quite
sure if it makes sense to include more
information or other information maybe
now that I think of it I think it's
probably a good idea to do to change it
a little bit huh
okay and now I'm in the middle of the
video anyway I'm going to going to try
just a moment
yeah so I'm back again I think this is
probably better right
so I'm then on the left hand side we see
some information about that problem
success rates and then stuff like that
yeah some text annoying same with Africa
don't have a premium of what it is
called membership anymore head at once
maybe I should get that seems kind of
interesting play the current position
against the computer and see common
problem mistakes yeah again playing it
against the computer I know but can be
useful in analysis yeah here the point
definitely was that I cannot really if I
go back I cannot capture it immediately
because this is no rogue edge to us to
move rook edge to king takes rook g2 is
it wrong because at some point light
takes and then it's stalemate like has
no move so nice um stalemate avoidance
problem okay let's do the next one
Wow so white has just taken on c1 and
we're looking at this
Black's point of view oh what a position
that's kind of crazy looking so like is
one pawn down first move most obvious
move would be would be b5 hmm why is b5
not working I think I think after b5
there might be 96 actually assess move
it looks very weird but yet be 596 rook
C 1 root C 1 and there's rook c8
threatened and I don't see what to do
against that that would lead to probably
losing endgame
yeah doesn't look good 96 Roxy 1 Roxy
one night f7 let's say or 85 let's do 85
85 that that's always a probably lost
end game so maybe b5 is not not really
working
hmm if there are something else that I
can play I can take on d5 which is kind
of similar mmm 85 96
oh so you have we have to check the g1 I
guess and 96 85 96
there's also look-see too by the way
Brooksie - and then there's g2 hanging
actually I have so that's also an
interesting point I don't have to take
on c1 necessarily I can give that check
which blocks the C file so be 596
whoopsy to check an interesting Quincey
to Bishop C - oopsie one
my deaf five or something that's that's
very tricky this position if I go 85 he
also has roughly one I mean II d5 rock
t1 is probably a problem anyway and not
a really great idea so probably it will
be B 5 B 596 looks it will check Queen
c2 bishop C - Roxy one or a crazy
position the bishop moves the still rook
c8 it never helps to move the Queen as
Lucas e ADA's no but then I can actually
move the Queen because he has to take
that one moment to to to take on c2 so I
can play let's say Queen h4 or something
but then looks it to again as rook c8
made Wow
and those the chest tempo problems are
notoriously tricky and I really are I
wonder if I got all the candidate moves
correctly so be 585 do have other moves
just just to consider I mean it are
there other moves what about let's say
queen edge for the center candidate move
I'm threatening
maybe queen f2 I've done I will
definitely threatened d5 then but Queen
Dido maybe yeah maybe maybe if if it was
something like Queen d2 then they'd
still be five and possibly Roxy - so
that's not so bad or interesting so this
this could be could be something but I
don't think that other moves make much
sense Knight a5 something like that to
just cover the six and that's not
necessarily bad that it activates that
piece and b5 then we'll definitely be
threatened but the sun's totally totally
off I really want us be 596 Roxy - Roxy
- Bishop c2 rook c1 is there no no good
move then I Knight a5 I can do Knight f5
in that position Knight f5 rook c2 9
takes these six takes Queen checks yeah
that's great that's the point maybe I
have 95 that's a huge difference I have
to give that check and then Knight f5
takes it Bishop takes something like d6
yeah that should be enough so be 596
routes it will check
look see - checking a1 I can take G -
yeah I think it that's it
be 596 looks it will check Quincy to
Bishop C to Roxy 1 and Knight f5 just in
time Knight f5 yeah that that should
that should be it
probably not but okay so be 596 that
that was right before so it just plays
out the move instantly it's it's correct
so I still can think about it now yeah
so look see one group see one then he's
always he has rook c8 that's unavoidable
and I'm getting a bad end game so Luke
c2 was my idea no way it seems to be
right bishop takes and that's it it
doesn't turn okay it shows that it shows
the the next couple of moves so I gained
I gained a couple of points here this is
the line that it follows here and the
Knight f5 exactly that was the point
so I saw up to this point and then I
stopped my calculation maybe he said too
early
yeah maybe something that works is six I
could have still considered but no it's
probably just too much material so I got
that one right oh okay yeah people
didn't like that so much didn't get many
stars I don't know I think it bosses
wasn't okay okay one so next one so
we've got black here again and Luke g1
was played it's equal material and okay
this is some background kind of thing
Wow interesting
ruk g7s is in remove the night I mean
that's Rooker Rupert g7 as a move first
thing first thing that came to our mind
she is back ranked like Knight f1 that
Sam if I go night f1 in this position
and where's he going with this book from
the two queen d1 major services in what
is he playing after night everyone
Brooke g7 hmm I don't see really what
he's doing Luke g7 okay I have to go to
age six and then what exactly where is
he going with this rook that does not
allow Queen d1 made
it's here now that one seems correct
actually the that is also to block block
that first rank so like 94 you can just
play route g2 or something like that or
take on now now maybe not Petrucci to so
I have to go
Knight f1 that Sony move that makes any
sense for that back rank idea where is
he going
that's really no square right which is 7
King age 6 I wonder because usually
those problems he have some kind of some
kind of hidden point that I might be
missing not everyone looks very simple
actually
yeah Luke which is 7 King edge 6 and
then what it's d2 hangs I don't get it
so I'm going to play that maybe I'm
wrong no I'm not
ok King f8 it's not going to go at all
so I didn't see that move is that what
is the point of it okay rook F 2 I
didn't see that but now I can go to C 4
for example
yeah okay so that was an easy one I only
gained gained a couple of points there
it was at least much much easier than
then than others so it also only has a
standard rating or firm over 1800 so I
got a somewhat weaker simpler problem
this time yeah okay next one okay now a
white wide side problem hmm I
interesting yeah well here there are a
couple of things that that come to mind
the knight on d5 is a dangerous
attacking piece and if white manages to
enter enter the position that will be
quite
nice with the Queen yeah a queen on f7
or something like that
Black has no check that's important for
counter plays white um White's King is
relatively relatively safe if I go Queen
f3
he has Queen e6 covering things so um I
move that I have to check his rook f7
just for the tempo
rook f7 King takes Queen f3 check King
g8 does 97 King g7s Queen f6 but there
is cooking aid might win f6 might be
might be an idea hmm
that was already pretty complicated
let's see it from Canada the moves if
there's some other candidate rules that
I might be might be missing
Roxy one is also a pretty attractive
looking move actually so possible
whoopsy 7 hmm
and this also 97 but 97 probably 23 I
don't know that that looks a bit a bit
wrong look II have 7s the most
interesting move takes Queen f3 King to
e8 I can also check him on f6 but that
looks kind of wrong so King e8 Queen f6
is that a move and threatening Queen is
seven mate what is got rook takes d5
which ends the whole thing so probably a
rook f7 is not going to work at all he
can escape to e8 hmm that's bad news
so rogue f7 we can pretty much discard I
guess Queen f3 we we had seen his answer
back
six so that's not working
Roxy one is the next move that that
comes to mind I think he probably he
probably has to go to Six to have look
at his seven in case of a Roxy seven
check that seems very likely yeah we
cannot go to be seven when Queen a six
root system Queen a six maybe because
he's looking at the d3 and have one
squares for counter flavored Roxy seven
looks pretty awkward anyway and there's
also queen of three witches probably
even better yes so Roxy 126s Queen Queen
f3 that that's going to window order 20
when yes so Roxy one is very likely the
right move
Roxy one queen is six if I check him on
c7 book c7 Luke d7 is there something I
don't see anything particularly great is
there something else
Queen f3 26 it's really sorry book c1
looks very very correct actually Roxy
one queen is 6 they're a completely
different idea that I'm not seeing
Bruce is soundless very normal d7 can I
do something I brought that I drew Conde
7 that's just protected by the Queen
some kind of technical idea I cannot I
don't have Forks or anything
mm-hmm okay that proves to be trickier
than thought I wonder if Cook f6 is a
move actually this is the final move
that might be a candidate that I have
not checked yet Brooke f6 for potential
route g6 Knight f6 IDM I mean this
counter play is limited he doesn't have
many many things that you can try look
f6 also prevents any Queen a6 business
maybe the rook f6 is actually very
interesting rook f6 rook f8 Queen f3
maybe that looks very dangerous actually
4 rupees six nine f6 now that does make
quite a bit of sense
look f6 rook takes d5 maybe you set a
point group g6 check King age 7 ticks on
d5 Queen f5 check that's
that's very problematic huh Wow okay
rook f6 disrupt e5 I might have Queen f3
there queen of three Europe d7 group g6
check I think that wins actually look at
six look t5 Queen f3 that might win ruku
g6 and rook f7 are very strong threats
yeah I think that wins
oops it was skype so rook f6 rock d5
Queen f3 hmm okay 810 route g6 check now
that wins it really wins I wonder look
f6 does he have any other defense look
f8 again rukia beta is also 97 so I
think we have six is probably the way to
go okay let's do that
it's right now that's good it's right I
wasn't totally sure so yeah and now as I
said 97 was my idea for Knight f5 I just
wonder if if maybe he's got some kind of
wacky count to play
this also rube g6o Queen f3
they all do look quite ok but 997 it's
they're really a drawback to that move
9797 rook f6 Knight c8 check on f1 just
one check actually or two checks you can
also check on f2 then
97 Queen 86 take the Queen I don't see
it I think 97 should win or is C having
some silent move the second move is
often the the more difficult one in
those problems there are a couple of
tempting options again here a group g6
for example which is six I don't really
see why look g6 wouldn't work to be
honest why why wouldn't that work group
g6 King h7 Knight f6 check rook f6 rook
f6 why am I not winning in this position
maybe I am and the other ones do not win
but why does Knight is 7 then not win
usually there is a clear-cut solution
there is no one there's not a secondary
option that's just one thing that wins
and that's ed 97 I wonder really last
night is having than not winning I mean
now I think Ruby 6 should win rook g6
King edge King h8 I just taken on on age
6 looked g6 king air 7 9 f6 chick rook
takes rook takes f6 I don't see blacks
big play there
he cannot invade with the quit the Queen
and I'm actually threatened covering Wow
I wait wait wait wait wait wait Bishop
b2 is that is that a problem I can go
back to f1
oh is it am i struggling there with my
own king I don't I don't really see why
it wouldn't work would be six but I also
see why 97 wouldn't work this is the
situation where you know in a real game
that's in a tournament a chance game
where you would think that there are two
solutions you would play one of them
while in a problem here you um you
really only only have one solution oh I
don't get it
I think 97 should win and ruku 6g 6 King
f7 is that a move I can take h6 I really
don't see what's wrong with it now I
know I'm missing something because
there's usually really only one solution
to those problems
rook g6 King h7 Knight f6 check take
Stig's
or isn't that such an easy win in the
first place is this this exchange up
position I mean my king is not grade
young it really isn't but if I go then
Queen f3 it looks like I've got
everything covered
we should be 2 at the end the swoop f1
hmm I don't see why G 6 is not winning
and neither do I see why 97 shouldn't
wind they both should win okay play
group g6 now it ok I will check later if
the other one was also winning ok here
Knight f6 was apparent move is there a
different one sometimes it really pays
off to have a second look but I don't
think so let's do that cheek and that's
it so it's right but really I would
really love to learn why a knight of
snotty 7s not working why isn't that not
working
I still don't get it still don't get it
if the Queen moves tonight at 5:00 we'll
win this war this thing will win this I
no of course not you can take with the
king you can take with the king very
very very yes sometimes then I do those
silly things you can take with the king
I just had a hallucination there
yeah the rook is not protected anymore
now I see it yeah if he moves the Queen
I think not quite sure Wayne was it um
yeah maybe I don't know I don't know
just put it on I just want to show that
it of course I take the case take the
rook so that was very simple stuff that
I that I just did not see okay so does
this make some ruku g6 that the winner
and the one that I read actually picked
yeah in this position this is the
relatively toughest threatening mate
okay I cannot draw any arrows yeah well
a stretch right so Queen say one
threatening mate and but I can cover
that in the in the line in the in the
database here this Queen III which has
the additional benefit of not just
covering sorry covering this and also
threatening Queen a7 so that's when yeah
I hope you enjoyed this 30 minutes of of
calculation and tactics I will do that
more often in the future thanks for
watching